You're welcome to this intelligence squared podcast with me, Helen Joyce.
I'm delighted to introduce our guests today. Helen Rose.
She's the editor of arrow magazine and co-author with James Lindsay.
I have a new book, cynical theories,
how activist scholarship made everything about race, gender, and identity,
and why this harms everybody it's out now.
Okay. Thank you for inviting me.
Oh, it's very exciting to have you on. I really enjoyed the book.
I actually bookmarked it as soon as I heard about it several months ago,
because I thought that's a book I need to read.
Oh, thank you. And I'm never quite sure.
People always tend to have an opinion very far in one direction or the other.
The world we live in.
And actually that's something we're probably going to talk about. Isn't it.
I wanted to start with that word. Cynical. I have the book on my phone.
I don't have the print copy or I'd show our audience,
but you've got the word critical and you have the word cynical written over it.
So it's like critical theories, but cynical theories instead. Cynical what?
Cynical.
Okay. So when postmodern is, post-modernism a Rose,
it was defined as a skepticism towards narratives.
And what annoys us is that this particular approach,
this critical approach considers itself to be the epitome of
skepticism. Whereas in fact,
being skeptical of meta-narrative has been something that been happening
throughout the modern period.
This is what the whole sort of scientific revolution was about.
How do I know this is true?
So we say that the theories that came out of these postmodern ideas,
aren't skeptical because skeptical is doubtful and it's still in search of some
kind of truth.
It's cynical because it begins with the assumption that everything is about
power and balances and people trying to protect their power.
And then it reads society through it.
So no idea about how people are working together,
sometimes in opposition sometimes,
but towards some variety of truth or objectivity or
understanding or any of those things.
Yeah, exactly. I think, um, uh, Joe, Alan Sokal and John Brickman, they,
they wrote, wrote it very well.
They said there's a specific skepticism in which we say,
how do we know this is true? And then we work out how to find out a bit is true,
how to falsify it, if it isn't true. And this is interesting and productive.
If you've got the kind of radical skepticism of the postmodern approach,
you don't even look for truth.
You just start with this idea that we can't actually obtain truth.
And what's interesting is, is what power dynamics are being are in play here.
You said the word power several times here. And I do want to come back to that,
but I want to say just one more thing.
I'll get you to comment on one more thing before we do that.
So you've said no twice.
I think meta-narrative so they're skeptical about metanarratives,
but it sounds like what you're saying is there is a meta-narrative they have
their own.
Yes. Th this is, um, the third generation. So in the sixties,
uh Jean-Francois Lyotard he described postmodernism as a skepticism towards
meta narratives, and that's all those big overarching explanations for things.
So Christianity obviously Marxism, um,
but science and progress as well. So he was skeptical of that.
And so were all of the first postmodernists they really took things apart. Um,
they didn't really try to build anything,
but as these few core ideas about power, knowledge,
and language have evolved over the last 50 years,
they have formed a meta-narrative of their own now.
So power, knowledge, and language,
and from reading your book power is what people have kind of innately
because of their characteristics and languages.
What brings the whole thing together?
How we talk about it and our discourses and knowledge is what we're creating by
discoursing if that's a verb, is that right?
Yes. So, um, it's, uh, Michel Fuko,
particularly who joined the words,
power and knowledge to make one power knowledge,
and this is what underlies everything. So it isn't that, um,
people are deliberately trying to exercise power over others necessarily
it's that people are born into certain positions in society that gives them a
certain relationship to power.
The powerful forces get to decide what is knowledge and what isn't.
And then this is legitimize. And everybody speaks, um, through this,
these discourses of, of knowledge, which really discourses of power.
So they can be called things like white supremacy, patriarchy, CIS,
normativity, heteronormativity, and we're all upholding them all the time.
By assuming that, um,
there is knowledge that is legitimate about these things.
So we've been quite abstract up to now,
we've talked about things like metanarratives and discourses,
and now you've started to hint at some rather specific versions of this and the
book you give a chapter each to several of these cynical theories. So, you know,
critical race theory, et cetera, et cetera, let's pick race.
Since you mentioned, uh,
you mentioned the white fragility or the white supremacy sort of idea.
That's very topical right now we have books like, um,
with people like Robin de Angelo, I'm talking about white fragility.
And so what's wrong with that. I mean, we, we do, we do live in a world where,
um, you know, people have been horribly oppressed on the basis of race. There,
there is, there is a hierarchy here, so are they getting it completely wrong?
Have they got some aspect of it, right.
The approach wrong. So if we're going to look at, um, racism,
there are a number of different ways to do this.
So the liberal approach to racism, which was, uh,
kind of put forward in Martin Luther King frequently,
this aims to take significance out of identity categories. So, you know,
while being black or being a woman could be important to your sense of who you
are.
It shouldn't tell society anything about your moral or social value or what role
you should play in the world.
So this is what the liberal approach is when critical race theory arose.
It took aim at that. Um,
particularly it didn't agree with the liberal approach of trying to be
colorblind.
It obviously it tends to interpret that as a willingness to be to racism,
which isn't a tool. The same thing, if you think being colorblind is a, is a,
is a positive thing that we should try, we should aim for in our society.
It means you oppose people who are not being colorblind,
people who are being racist. So when we look at racism,
we need the most rigorous scholarship that's out there. And there are some very,
very rigorous, uh, scholars out there. They, um,
take a materialist empirical approach. So you could look at the, um,
research into the criminal justice system, by someone like Michelle Alexander,
for example. And you will find her looking at systems at,
at laws at numbers. And she'll be analyzing this in a, in a,
in a strong and steady way. But if you go with somebody like Robin D'Angelo,
she is all about, um, theory, her own interpretation of how,
what all white people must think how all black people must experience things.
She wants people to admit all white people to admit that they have been
socialized into believing that black people are inferior in various ways,
and then work to dismantle that even though that isn't actually ever possible.
So one of her, um, when she,
she wrote a number of tenants with a team,
and one of them was the question is not, does racist, did racism occur,
but how did racism manifest in this situation?
So it's assumed to always be there.
It reminds me very much of the logic of the ducking stool. You know,
you've got the, you know, if the witch sinks,
she wasn't a witch and if she floats, well, we will burn her.
So there's just no way. I'm just,
there's nothing that you can do in this situation.
No, exactly. There's the Angelo. She gives us two choices.
You can either be racist and acknowledge it and work against it,
or you can be in, be racist and in selfish denial of it.
So it's unforeseeable and that's obvious that's a feature. That's not a bug,
I guess, because she doesn't want anybody denying it.
How can this actually have caught on when I thought we had, you know,
I thought we had actually solidified the idea that what was the power of the
modern world was that we have periods that we could test and we could falsify
them and we could reject them if they weren't good enough and replace them by
new ones. How did that even catch on.
This is what has been being undermined. This is the liberal approach.
Then it's what Jonathan Rausch called liberal science,
that process where everybody can raise any idea they want.
Anybody else can challenge that idea.
There's the belief that we can all get at ideas and examine them on their own
merits.
And that the individual has agency to reject some ideas or not hold others.
So this to the postmodernist is very, very naive.
It's either an extreme naivety and an inability to see the
invisible powers, power structures,
or it's a selfish attempt to protect one's own privilege.
So you see per some extent that there is of course truth in this,
because if we look at how our understanding of homosexuality has changed,
for example, dominant discourse is for a long time. So it was a heinous sin.
Then it said it was a shameful disorder.
Now the dominant discourse around homosexuality is some people are going to get
over it. So this has changed, but whereas the liberals would say,
this has changed because we were able to look at it, talk about it,
discuss it, apply science to it. And, um, you know,
really sort of compare arguments for what homosexuality is.
Does it have any moral valance at all? And that was how we overcame,
um, prejudice against homosexuality. But the, the,
the discourse there is the descendants of the postmodernist would say,
this is naive. And what all that has happened is that, um,
the ways of talking about things have changed. We are still living in a very,
um, heterocentric and a centrist society,
and that those power structures are still there and they still need to be
dismantled.
And they think that we're going to do that by changing the way that we talk
about things.
Yes, precisely if, if language creates social reality,
changing language can create a better one.
And if you think that, like, if one thinks that, uh,
we're in this sort of invisible web, this, this power web, and we're all of us,
it positioned according to our characteristics,
we maybe even don't see these things until somebody has taught us the techniques
of critical whatever theory, how can, like,
it sounds like we're trying to pull ourselves up by our bootstraps.
If you believe that you can change the way that you talk,
and that will change reality, like it is incredibly pessimistic.
And I don't know how they think, if you think like that,
how they think that you can't even change your language.
Well, some theorists have argued that, that it's almost impossible.
Kristy Dotson. Um, for example, when she does her, um, conceptualize,
conceptualizing epistemic oppression, she says that third level,
that one where you have to try to,
to even speak in the language that you have,
trying to see that there is a problem when you only have the language,
the epistemic resources that you have is almost impossible.
So there is a lot of, um, of pessimism there,
but there's also a certain simplicity to it.
And there's a certain appeal to it because people feel as though we're only at
the beginning, we can't, they don't know,
not even that the most advanced theorists in the world know or exactly how
this power system works,
but what we're doing is we're picking at it where we're digging at it.
We're trying to see it.
We're uncovering more bits of it because it's unfortified bubble.
Somebody can identify racism within any interaction.
And as long as it's, um, according to the theory,
it will be deemed or authoritative. It will be correct. So there's,
there's a lot of, um, a lot of room for people to play with these ideas,
for them to interpret things. And,
and to them feel like you're really uncovering new ground and,
and setting the scene for improving things.
Right? So they feel like they're making progress because when there's no,
falsifiability, everything is sort of progress. Every bit of thing that you say.
Yeah. I mean, it's beginning be able to see it,
that that's the thing the Angelo often says,
we need to make it visible and then we can get at it.
I mean,
I think the second bit of that doesn't necessarily follow from the first,
but since I don't agree with the first either,
I think that's going to be relevant. Um,
I thought it was very interesting the way you talked. I think it was, it was,
um, Megan, an article just very recently,
you said this thing about what cancelled culture really is.
And there was a great explanation that the point of cancel culture is that if
people are saying wrong things, I know it was wrong.
Things are creating wrongness and silence,
and them is extremely moral thing to do and silencing them by any means really.
Um, and you don't have to debate them, debating them will be bad.
Have I got that about right?
Yes, exactly. I think this makes intuitive sense to humans. I mean,
this is why there have been such strong laws against heresy and blessing for me,
because the idea is you can corrupt society. You can taint and dam others.
So, you know, when we had awful things like the inquisition,
this was a moral endeavor because the attempt was to stop this
corruption from spreading and damming, a lot of people to hell. And so, yes,
they wanted to put very,
very strong disincentives in place for people to question
the orthodoxy of religion.
Now this is a different situation because we're in a different time,
but the same, um, the same, sorry,
my husband has not got his keys. Can you let that in please?
Should I ask you the question again? I think you were going well,
so I don't want to meet people from the inquisition. That was good.
So, uh, yeah, so we, um, yeah,
even with things like the inquisition,
which where was such a sort of terrorizing, um, thing,
there was a moral imperative, uh, underneath that,
the idea was that if people, um, speak heresy, if they,
they challenge the, um, the orthodoxy, but the truth of God's this,
this can, um, this, this will corrupt and, um,
and taints the rest of society and cause, and cause people to be down to hell.
So there's this incentive to really make, um, to,
to ensure that people are thinking and speaking in the right way for the good of
everybody. And that's what you get right now. I mean, the,
the strongest mantra I think that people are wanted, uh,
expected to repeat at the moment is trans women are women. And so what,
no matter what you actually believe about trans identity,
I'm fully in support of trans trans rights and people identifying as they
wish to with, you know,
there's obviously conversations that need to be happened about spaces and
sports, but no matter what you think about this, we,
it's difficult to notice that the emphasis is,
is very much on language.
Are you saying things which suggests that trans women aren't women,
the way to respond to that is not with an argument.
So we don't have people arguing back and forwards as much as we have them and
throwing mantras at each other as if they're trying to, um,
to, to out outspeak each other on the level of these discourses.
If I say trans women are women often enough, if enough people say it,
that will make the social reality be what is needed for the acceptance of trans
people.
Yeah, it's interesting because I had, honestly,
I had sort of thought that anyone who hung on to a mantra that much couldn't
possibly really believe it, you know, that if you're,
if you feel secure in your own ideas, I'd always thought,
but then this just shows that I'm from a previous generation.
I always thought if you were secure in your ideas,
you wouldn't mind debating them.
You'd feel confident that you could answer any criticism that people put
forward. But I think what you showed, uh, you know, and you, you,
you gave me a different way to conceive of this.
Was it the very saying of these things was a harm.
And I haven't understood that before that, you know, I was creating an evil,
according to these people, by saying things even possibly,
if I were saying them on my own,
in a room normally even meant to think that I'm not even meant to say them in my
head, I guess.
Yeah. I mean, this is why we get the argument that, um,
gender critical feminists are involved in the murder of trans women,
even though, you know,
trans women do seem to be particularly vulnerable to violence, but this isn't,
um, has never been by a gender critical feminist,
but there's this idea that they're speaking into a narrative that de validates
in validates de legitimize is, um, trans people.
It creates a hostile environment and one in which it is acceptable for them to
be abused by people who have completely different ideas and aren't feminist at
all. So it's, um.
It seems quite remarkable. I mean, it seems, you know, I mean,
I lived in Brazil for several years and I mean,
that is one of the places where trans women are murdered. I mean, you know,
it's actually one of the hotspots, but in Rio de Janeiro,
because there's a lot of street workers there, you know,
they're not listening to what gender critical feminists are saying. I mean,
these men, it's nothing to do with, it's nothing to do with that. It's,
you know, some mixture of violence homophobia, to be honest,
self hatred, et cetera, et cetera, you know, and just being violent.
Is anyone really so convinced if they think it through,
or is the point that they're stopping themselves from thinking it through,
by saying the mantra? Like, is it a thought stopping cliche?
I think it's,
I have a tendency to think that it is actually quite normal,
quite intuitive to humans to think that our words have more power than
they do.
I think that the idea that if we can just get everybody
saying the right thing, everything will be okay,
actually makes a lot of sense to us, whereas storytelling the species.
So I think what's more counter-intuitive to us is the idea that there can be
worth in getting people together who have two different views on a thing and
getting them to argue their own side, using evidence in a reasoned argument.
This,
this doesn't seem to make a lot of sense to a lot of the activists right now.
And it hasn't made a lot of sense, historically.
I think people like you and I and our generation and people who have been
involved in having these kinds of conversations, we can,
it seems that this is the obvious way. You know, we talk about things. We,
we exchange ideas. This is how we progress,
but it doesn't seem to be that intuitive to a lot of people.
Yeah. So maybe it was a brief period,
but it was a brief and very glorious periods.
I think it's something we have to, we have to hang on to it.
We have to constantly reinforce it. Otherwise it will,
we are likely to lose it and it will be the most powerful narrative wins.
So what let's see, um,
I want to ask you what you think this means for two particular large areas,
very important areas of society that I think are really under attack at the
moment. And one is academia and the other one is journalism.
So academia seems to have pretty much fallen to these ideas,
at least large chunks of it.
I th I think it's certainly, um, very much overpowered by it.
Of course you get, um,
I don't think the majority of academics hold these views and that you don't find
them in, uh, in every field,
they really sort of concentrated in a cluster in the humanities and also on
campus culture.
But anybody who goes against them is likely to find themselves
in trouble. So this is what I was I found when I'm studying, um,
late medieval women's religious writing. Now I can look,
I can do work that I can be proud of as long as I'm not looking at what
sex is, what gender is, how it works in any way,
that's going to go against the dominant narrative. You know?
So if somebody wanted to be a historian and they wanted to look at agriculture
or something,
like it goes through their whole lives without becoming a Cropper with this.
But if you're a scientist and you want to look at say how sex differences exist
between men and women, then you're going to find yourself in trouble.
It's interesting, isn't it?
Because I think that's a bit of it's that people don't see if they're outside,
what we might call a knowledge producing industry.
So I'll count journalism to that, even, even if it's not very fair, but it's,
it's the,
it's the self-censorship it's before you even get to the area that's touchy.
So it's not a bit,
not about the people who were sacked it's about the people who never said
anything more than anything else.
Yes. I hear it from a lot of academics.
And I hear from a lot of people generally, who write to me and say, I, you know,
I think I'm the only person in my organization who is concerned about
this. And then quite often now I happen to know that they're not,
and I can put them in touch with somebody else.
And I think there's a lot more people who are, um,
concerned about it or who at least don't agree with it.
I think with a lot of liberals on the left who still actually have those kind of
beliefs that I'd like them to have about the value of different ideas and the
exchange of debates and consistent principles,
they tend to understand the social justice approaches a more
friendly and liberal thing than it is and feel that they should be supportive of
it. And the scholar is producing it because the problem on the right is,
um, is a more severe one. If you, if you are a leftist, yes,
we're going to worry about the rise of right-wing populists.
And they then get rather annoyed with people on the left, who are saying yes,
but this is a problem that's on the left. It is a problem.
We do need to address it.
And more than that, they're connected, aren't they and people. Yeah.
So you tell me about how you think they're connected then.
I don't think, I think there are two ways. If you,
if you are a leftist and you want left-wing parties to win and be able to, um,
Institute left-wing policies, there are two things you have to do.
You have to show the problem with the party on the right,
and you have to make your own party,
a strong one and one that people can respect.
And I don't think that's happening on the left at the moment.
I think that there's this division between the identitarian,
the radicals and the liberals on the left. And at the moment,
the identity politics left is the one that is most visible.
It's the one that corporations and politicians feel that they have to appease.
And I think it's driving people right now. I can't know how many people went,
right, because of this. And, um, so it's not very helpful to guess,
but I do think that if we could have a more consistently liberal left,
then we could see,
then we'd have been a better chance of getting people to vote left again.
So the profession that worries me most,
I have to say because it's the one I'm in is journalism.
And I think you see a lot of the same tendencies in particular.
The self-censorship not surprisingly, I suppose. I mean,
a lot of money has gone out of journalism.
A lot of people have gone out of journalism. It's become a low paid, um,
very temporary and casual sort of work that young people come into.
And they have no time, no specialism, no support from older journalists.
And of course, they're all graduates now.
And most of them have come in from the sorts of courses where they learn this
sort of stuff.
So I'm absolutely a standard how fast this has happened to the journalism has
been hollowed out.
And I also see this as part of the political problem because
ordinary people slowly get the sense that they're not actually reading what's
going on. They're reading a,
sort of a self censored version of it in what are meant to be the papers of
record. So you have a, you have your own magazine,
you editor as sort of a new magazine.
Is this part of the motivation for you that you see no other place to put the
sorts of things that you want to say?
Yeah. And th that was why area was, um,
was created in the first place by amalgam Mali. He wanted something that wasn't,
um, left-wing or right-wing, or both,
but something that would have views from both sides,
but would argue them straightforwardly with, um, evidence and reason.
And so that, that is what we try to do.
We have quite a lot of leftists who write for us,
but few of them are the social justice leftists.
They tend to be socialists or, um, social Democrats.
And we have quite a lot of conservatives as well. And, and, um, and Christians,
and they will write from, from their belief systems. And this,
I think works well. We don't require people to be apolitical,
but we do require them to both state what that,
what political position they're coming from is,
and try to look charitably and concede much as they can to the one they're
criticizing. Yeah.
Okay. I'm going to take a bit of a leap, a sort of a sidestep here and say,
and how fascinating I find it endlessly fascinating,
the way that race in one bucket. And then we might say sex, gender,
and sexuality in another bucket,
how incredibly differently theorized these two things are so race,
which actually is this fluids blurbs sort of category.
You know, I mean the,
the race line was drawn differently in different countries at different times,
et cetera, is regarded as the most rigid, possible thing.
And sex, gender sexuality. When you know, sex is incredibly rigid,
sexuality mode for fields, for most people, quite binary, not everybody,
but most gender less. So, but I mean, compared to the race, you know,
how did that happen? How did he end up sort of almost the wrong way round there?
Okay. So I think that we've come from different, um, different places.
So theory,
which is where a lot of the sort of gender theory and then trans activism comes
from that's the most purely post-modern.
So it believes that there is a problem with having stuck with knowledge and that
it's been constructed in the service of power. So to get at that,
we have to look at the categories through which we think, and to try to,
to blur those boundaries, dismantle those categories,
and stop putting people into them.
They believe that if we get rid of all,
all categories that aren't, you know, uh,
feminine women attracted to men or masculine man attracted to women,
then the world will become a more welcoming place to the people who don't, um,
not be fitted for the pathways. So we've got that whole, um,
fluid thing going on there. And in fact, has become, uh,
a verb and to something is to blur the boundaries and to mix up the
categories. So that that's one particular theory and it relies quite a lot on,
um, dairy Darren Fuko. So when we're going into critical race theory,
this comes from a different lineage that has quite a lot of, um,
of input from the radical new left.
And then it has the post-modern influence, um, on top. So Kimberly Crenshaw,
when she described intersectionality,
she described it as contemporary politics by which he meant the radical
activism, um,
linked to postmodern theory by which she meant the idea of everything being
culturally constructed, but she wanted, um,
some acceptance of objective truth to be there.
She criticized the postmodernists saying that, you know,
we can't just dismantle everything.
We have to accept that some things are objectively true,
or we can't achieve anything.
So those systems of power and privilege had to be seen as true.
And I think because this comes from America and because there really has been
that rigid line in America, you know, there has been that one drop rule.
If you are black at all, then you are black. And so this,
the whole sort of, um,
identity politics to push back at this has taken this as well as,
as a solid category. They don't think that race is a biological category.
They do think it's a social construct,
but they think it's been constructed very simply into white supremacy and black
subordination.
Hmm.
How can we get some of the things that I never talked about in this whole world
view that are actually to do with power in particular money in class?
How can we get money in class, back into this sort of discussion poverty?
I never hear it. I never actually hear poverty or poor exception.
It's kind of tagged on to other things, you know, poor black women or, you know.
I mean, I, I mean,
this is why it's been the Marxist who have been criticizing the postmodernist
for longest,
and we still have the traditional Marxists who are still saying you are
dividing the working class. This is now all about rich, um, uh,
black and white people. Usually in universities,
we're not looking at economics or class at all.
Now this is an entirely Bush war enterprise. And, um, you know,
that they're criticizing on these grounds.
And so they get quite annoyed when people then call what we're seeing now,
Neo Marxism, because this has nothing to do with Mark's.
You can't blame him for this,
but I think that there are more connections with the whole sort of revolutionary
idea, but leaving class out is I think one of the,
the,
the most serious drawbacks of the critical race approach,
because we, we can look at race certainly,
and there are re you don't always have to only look at class.
I think the Marxists are a bit restricted if they only want to look at class in
particular, in a country in which race has been significant for so long,
but by only including class,
when somebody has another intersecting identity that is marginalized,
we're going to lose a lot of the, um, of the,
the sort of empirical analysis that we could have to actually make things
better. Um, a lot of the reason that, um,
that black Americans have such a lower, lower outcomes in life, generally,
it surely because they've only been allowed to try to rise out of the lowest
positions for about two generations.
Now we know that the best indicator of an individual success is if their
parents have been successful. So it's not going to happen straight away,
and it's not going to happen unless we look at social and material factors,
as well as potential prejudice.
And it also seems something that is quite obviously going to create
pushback, because if you've got, I mean, I think you mentioned this in the book,
you would easily get a hypothetical example of, you know,
very poor white person, like somebody with a really, really hard life.
And if the only thing you have to say to that person is if you've been black,
it would have been even worse. It's like, come on. You know,
and if the person is saying is, is,
is a university graduates or whatever race is painful,
it sounds like nothing has anything to offer you.
And you may as well just go off to the right.
Yes. I think this does make a lot of, um, of working class.
People feel alienated. We've seen the surge to the right from the working class,
both here in the UK, although we can't sort of put too much emphasis on,
on that being anything to do with the social justice,
because there was the whole Brexit thing going on as well. But yeah,
the working class do seem to be going to the right.
They see Trump as having their interests more than mine.
They see Bryce Johnson as having their interest more than mine. Now this is,
this is a really strange development and I think critical social justice ideas.
I've got to take some responsibility for that.
So there's something else that you talked about in the book that I thought was
really also clarifying for me was that we have three levels of analysis.
We could say individual and group and universal. And as a liberal,
the emphasis is really on individual and universal.
So we are human beings and that's what we share, but also we're individuals.
So we have our own interests.
Whereas all these sort of cynical theories that you talk about are really at
that middle level of group as maybe you could talk a little bit about that.
And whether you think liberals could maybe learn something from that,
or whether you think that particular slice way of slicing things through should
just be abandoned.
No, I, I,
I think it would be great if we didn't have to think in terms of group,
but as a tribal territorial species, I think we always will have to.
So I think sometimes when the, um, the socialists and the social justice,
um, scholars have criticized liberalism for focusing too much on the
individual,
having access to everything and our shared humanity and not enough on group,
they do make a point because it's quite simplistic to think, well,
we just want every individual to be able to do everything and not look at things
that could be holding them back from that,
which could be their class could be their race could be their sex.
So we do need to have that kind of focus. And I think the,
the liberal civil rights movements of the sixties and seventies,
liberal feminism, gay pride, the civil rights movements,
they were largely driven by this liberal Universalist impulse. They said,
we want to have the same rights as everybody else,
which is very different to the identity politics approach, which is,
we are this group with this source of power.
You are a different group and we are in conflict. Right.
Right. So you were saying maybe the group is the way that, uh,
let's see an inequality lawyer or might look at this will be to say, well,
you know, this could be indirect discrimination.
There could be something here that it's a facially neutral policy,
as they say in American law, meaning everybody has access,
but actually not really. And that could be discrimination.
So you can kind of fit it into a liberal framework.
You don't have to go the whole way down to, you know, group sources.
I think we need a liberal framework overall,
but one that takes input from, um,
from class analysis and from identity analysis, because we,
that, that is how humans work.
I think the danger of focusing too much on groups is that,
that brings out the worst of human nature because we are tribal because it's so
easy for us to think, well, of our own group demonize an out-group,
but we become callously indifferent to people who aren't on our team.
That's something we need to always protect against.
And we need an element of liberal humanism to do that,
to be thinking of as many people as possible as coming within our Sierra of,
of concern. So my, my fear with identity politics is that it will lead.
Um, and it is leading to really harsh conflict and an inability to,
to see each other as human beings or as individuals.
So the first time I heard of intersectionality,
I thought that's what it was trying to do, that it was saying,
think about the way that this could be different for people who are different,
you know, think,
are you actually thinking how this would look to a feminist who's black?
Are you thinking about how this might feel to someone who's disabled?
And I really liked that idea,
but somehow that's not at all how the word has come to mean.
No, I mean, it, it really could be valuable. I think Patricia Hill Collins who,
um,
sort of developed the concept of intersectionality along with Kimberly Crenshaw,
she points out that in the U S there are very, very different stereotypes,
um, for black women than there were for black men or white women.
So a black woman could be discriminated against in an employment position
because there's this stereotype that she was be, um, aggressive,
sexually promiscuous, all these other things, which don't,
aren't considered to be traits of white women. So there, you know,
that that was a valid point that you can't really say, well,
this company employs white women. So there's no sex ed when it closed back men.
So there's no racism if there is a prejudice specifically against black women.
So that needs to be in there. But unfortunately right from the start, um,
Kimberly Crenshaw was critical of liberalism. She said,
it wasn't the way to go.
She said that taking social significance out of categories, um,
sort of disempowers people,
we need to have a less universal group orientated approach.
And she wanted to go with postmodernism, which is all about social constructs.
And that really kind of shot itself in the foot because now everything is
interpretive.
Everything is theoretical first and then trying to make things fit it.
And then you get, um,
people in opposition and in conflict and in competition with each other
until you're, you're ending up with this, um, really combative, uh,
approach at looking at what could be a useful theory of understanding how
different kinds of identity can, can compound each other.
Yeah. And also you have to say then if you,
if you want to take this identity first approach, you have to say that,
say a black woman who doesn't agree with you is somehow got a false
consciousness or she's wrong, or she's theorized it wrong because you, you know,
hot, the black woman or whatever position actually is.
You end up with somebody like Robin, you know,
Robin de Angelo telling people what they should think. Really. Yes.
This is, um, this is something I've been wanting to write about recently.
I've just started reading, um,
a lot of black conservatives again in the American context,
because I want to see a range of how people are addressing racism.
And so I've been reading Shelby Steele, and I think he's attitude.
He really has got this kind of pull yourself up by the bootstraps attitude.
That's really typically conservative personal responsibility thing.
And I'm looking at him and I'm thinking,
I think this for an individual is probably a really, really good attitude,
but it's no good for a social policy. You know,
conservatism isn't a black conservatism is the same as other kinds of
conservatives. I mean,
it focuses too much on the individual's power and not enough on social,
on the responsibility of society.
So I think we do need to keep pointing out to people who say, well,
this is listen to black people,
listen to people of color that this is not a monolithic entity.
We have a number of black intellectuals and they are to be found all over the
political spectrum.
What would really be helpful is if people try to look at the good and bad
points of all of them, and I think Cornell West does this quite well.
I really liked, um, reading his race matters because he he's.
One of his sentences started my fellow Christian and friend Glenn Lowry.
And then he went through about how he's completely wrong about everything.
And I said, yes, this is what we need kind of attitude.
Do you think.
They are unfair to say that postmodernism is a new religion? Is that, uh,
an apt characterization?
Well, we, we did a talk on that and we said, no,
but it does.
I think fulfill the same social and psychological needs as religion,
I think for purposes of, um, the amount of power it can,
they allow to have on over how other people think and speak,
it should be treated as equivalent to a religion in that it should be a
protected, people can believe it. They can say so they can live by it,
but they mustn't, um, impose it on other people.
Right. Right. I find,
I must say I find the whole thing extremely pessimistic,
because it's got a lot of things built into it that make it very
hard to course. Correct. So for example,
this thing of double binds or this thing that, um, if you criticize it,
you're just proving that you're a very bad person.
So it seems to be something that's going to go and go and go and then crash.
And I find it hard to be optimistic. You,
I think are a bit more optimistic than me,
or at least you're pretending to be in your last chapter you went through when
you said what was worth keeping and what wasn't honestly.
I'm not as optimistic as I was a year ago when I finished writing that chapter
before we saw all the, um, um, protests that we're seeing now,
I still don't think this can last for long because it's,
it is too counter-intuitive and it's really, um,
sort of setting up against the majority,
which that's what worries me particularly.
I think we could actually see a pushback, um, on,
in the form of white identity politics and socially conservative ideas about
sex and gender.
And that this could actually set us back considerably with the amount of
progress that we've already made towards, um, racial and gender equality.
But I am optimist because I used to,
as a set of ideas that can survive for long term. And the more extreme it gets,
I think the more liberal lefties who aren't completely committed to social
justice ideas, or having to admit that there is a problem, right.
And having to sort of distance themselves from it.
So I seen the rise of a group that is sort of between me
and the social justice people. So they are now, um,
criticizing me that they're saying that I'm, I'm too dismissive of, um,
social justice, but they're also picking out the problems in social justice.
So I don't think that, um, little tribe really existed even, uh,
a couple of years ago.
So this is something in the leftist academic sphere,
which is already starting to distance itself in a way that it hadn't before.
So yeah, I think it will happen.
I think it will gradually get marginalized unless there's
something dramatic happens first. And I'm afraid that in America,
we could even see something equivalent to a civil war at the moment. I don't,
it's, it's escalating so fast. It's really quite worrying.
Okay. I don't want it to end on such a pessimistic note.
So I want to ask you if you could pick the things from the
cynical theories, because quite often, you know, you're very,
you're a very generous interlock is very, you, you, you often say, you know,
I really like this idea or I get something from this,
or I think there was a really good insight here. Could you pick,
say three things that you think, you know,
you learned that you'd like to rescue from the conflagration if there is a
conflagration?
Um, so I think in theory, um,
the pointing out that the way we see sexuality has changed so much in the
last century and we shouldn't be too confident that we're now getting it right.
That is something I could certainly agree with. Um, within critical race theory.
Hmm. That's a little bit more tricky because it's, so, um,
it it's so dogmatic at the moment and it's gone down the path of,
of Robin de Angelo. However,
I think that we need to point out that there are still some very good,
um, scholars looking at racial issues who are still accepted within that.
That's fair. Like I particularly, like, as I said,
Michelle Alexander and she is still well-regarded by, um,
the majority of critical race theory.
So I think there's space for some improvement there.
And then when we come to disability and fat studies, there's,
there's some good work in there where we're trying to sort of move the
responsibility to be, um, you know,
with disabled people to be fully, um,
active in society from the disabled individual to society,
to make society more accommodating of disabled people. And, um,
when it comes to obesity to, to not consider people, uh,
people's worth in terms of their weight,
to such an extent that that actually is a stigma, which isn't helpful.
So we can, I think, support those ideas. Um,
fortunately there's been a lot of nonsense about how, you know,
being healthy as a social construct, but there,
there are good intentions in there. And I think if you've got, um, shared goals,
but different methods, that's, that's something you can work with.
Well, that's a nice place to stop. Thank you so much, Helen.
That was a great discussion. I really enjoyed it.